cement is an essential building block
for just about any construction project
Jordanian factories produce millions of
tons of it each year but the plants here
are only operating at about 50 percent
capacity
local demand in the building industry
simply isn't there as the Jordanian
economy struggles so Jordans builders
are looking outward hoping to re-enter
neighboring countries cut off by
conflict very building and exporting
opportunities in Syria and Iraq will
provide a huge number of job
opportunities in Jordan but no one can
get into the Syrian market as of now
because of the sanctions and other
obstacles
whenever the war ends in Syria
reconstruction should mean contracts
worth hundreds of billions of dollars
but with Syria being an international
outcast there are a few international
investors willing to fund the rebuilding
projects they're still Jordanian
contractors are trying to be the first
in line to go back in for joint
investment projects we are the private
sector and we cooperate with businesses
anywhere and everywhere we're trying to
avoid the political issues but at the
end of the day we are affected by
politics for Jordanian firms hoping to
profit from reconstruction projects in
Syria from rebuilding hospitals schools
and other infrastructure there are
considerable obstacles despite being
right next door a former trade minister
told us that he and other Jordanian
business leaders were warned by the US
government
not to go back in Syria and work or face
US sanctions the Jordanian Business
Association says it was briefed by US
officials earlier this year about the
seizure Syrian civilian Protection Act
the proposed US law which would sanction
any non-american providing construction
or engineering services to the Syrian
government it's passed the House in
Washington and is up for debate in the
Senate we thought that we could help in
the rebuilding Syria so far we were not
being able to receive any I will say
tenders or proposal from the Syrian side
but definitely the Jordan a contractor
will be
more than happy to help in the
reconstruction of Syria while intended
to punish Syria's government for attacks
on civilians US sanctions actual or
threatened are crippling Syria's ability
to trade and rebuild and the potential
for companies in Jordan to make money by
helping repair and rebuild their broken
neighbor Andrew Chappell al Jazeera
Amman